Look,
what a semi-new top tip.
This is the stainless Chevrolet,
a two-point zero turbo car that you find two thousand and nineteen,
do you know how cheap ninety-four
thousand reais is for a two-point zero turbo car,
this engine is used by the Camaro in the
United States for the entry version top the car.
I had one of those Premier ball show.
Now,
if you buy it and I'm going to show you the upgrade that's being done on it.
I'm safe,
right?
Now,
if you stay out of touch with reality,
I can give you another tip.
Alamo,
the Alamo is present throughout Brazil,
is headquartered in the south,
São Paulo,
Rio de Janeiro and covers the entire national territory.
If you have a semi new car and it was expensive for you to have it protected,
you know that you can count on the wing that has third
party damage of up to two hundred thousand reais and you
can rest assured that it is a very reliable institution.
Beauty,
let's go now to the tips.
Since he paid cheaply,
he bought a two-point zero turbo car for ninety-four thousand.
It is not this version that Premier is more expensive.
Input LT version you will find from this value,
let's take a look at the upgrade you can do.
This one has the sound.
Do you know who?
This is the compartment that we use on Star
motos to store the door so it doesn't hurt.
Look whose buzzard factory sound is?
It's just good,
it's good,
but it can get better.
We will also put a neon here at the door,
or the door will look really nice now.
Hey,
have you seen another speaker?
Buse closely,
so let's go.
look
it's simple,
it's bad,
it's not good,
but it can get better.
Take a close look here,
it's paper,
very simple,
but with a project that can be even better if you do some upgrades,
such as acoustic insulation,
you can put an acoustic blanket here to improve
the sound of the original speaker or replace it,
you can replace it with 1 much better,
just 1 look at what I'm going to show you,
this is 1 Italian,
we can replace it with a speaker like that or even
amplify it we use the saundista amplifier here on Star motos,
here we have a buse sub UF,
this one is from a Panamanian Porsche of one and a half
million reais made germany and this german fia ó paper too.
So we can improve a lot now that the car is top,
we can put the remap of the s.
f.
X can have three hundred horses in this car is an animal,
not only the remap but also the pedal,
the cheetah to take the throttle delay,
this car doesn't even have much delay,
but it gives an even greater performance.
Look how cool it is,
right?
Let me close.
What an amazing car.
Now let's go for a ride,
shall we?
You can also put on the white lamp,
which I think will look more attractive.
We have motorcycles here at Star and inside.
This one is evil,
huh?
Nice interior garden,
huge sunroof,
very nice panel.
There's a car there and it has a traditional American car smell.
Look at that cool car.
And then he liked the beast's semi-new tip.
If you are going to buy,
know how to quote now throughout Brazil with the Alamo.
And it took a lot of protection for your car.
She knows you can count on her too.
Beauty this here.
One more top tip,
huh?
What car will I tell you about?
I miss you.
Look at the 2 nozzles on the discharge pipe that this will do.